Don't expect him
to pop out of the huddle or strut by
with a temple high cheerleading squad.
But on game day, this Army infantryman
based in Texas
can be found in the stands,
standing up for his favorite cheerleader
Andre Simmons
went viral for cheering
along with his daughter.
Did the military teach you
those dance moves?
No, they did not.
His 15 year old daughter, Joslyn,
taught him all day wildcat.
And now he's earned himself a nickname.
Oh, well,
I have no one here
that I have no one to here
that he's cheered out of the century.
He's a one man pep rally.
Say, fan boys.
He says he does it to spend time
with his daughter
and make up for being away from his wife
and five kids while on military duty.
Joining them in are things that they love
and do they love it?
They're not embarrassed, right?
At first she was embarrassed,
but now she's totally into it.
They maintain an eye contact
as he shows off his moves
and she displays a smile from ear to ear
the entire time.
CHEERING on the Wildcats
that has become a cool cat and then, hey,
cat, let's get
you guys are more comfortable with us.
There's
nothing like an army infantryman
armed with pompoms to cheer.
Also,
Jenny, most senior
New York